Some people might consider this
conspiracy, but are we being primed for
this end of the world scenario? To be
fearful of this outer space being that
is coming and therefore fight it. It's
interesting. There is this obsession
with the end of the world. But where
does this concept even come from?
>> Have you guys ever seen some of those
end of the world movies?
>> Yes.
>> Tons of them.
>> Armageddon. Ice Age.
>> Uh-huh. you you know what was always
weird to me is they would release almost
two at the same time from different
studios. I was like what what's the
purpose of that? It's like so weird it's
almost like I wonder if they know that
some people are like you know priming
the pump but they didn't see that movie.
So then they're like do another one. I
don't know. But that is a weird
phenomenon.
>> It's interesting. There's like this
obsession with the end of the world.
Where does concept come from? It really
comes from the Bible, right? but not in
the way they portray it. Because usually
it's like the end of the world is
coming, but then they're able to fight
off whatever comet is coming to the
world, the flood, the ice age, the
creature that's coming to attack and
destroy everybody.
>> Transformers, I mean, you just go down
the list like
>> it's everywhere. Independence Day,
>> Star Wars, there's a death planet that's
going to destroy the planet. You know
what I mean? It's like they've been
working on this for a long I guess you
could ask the question then some people
might consider this conspiracy, but are
we being primed for this end of the
world scenario, but then it's like,
>> are you hearing this so much
>> that basically you're just like like,
oh, it's just entertainment. I've heard
it so many times. I don't have to worry
about Yeah.
>> You cry wolf. Well, and then you wonder,
are these completely original ideas
or are they people taking ideas from the
Bible? Because when you take chapters
like Matthew 24
>> Yes.
>> and other prophetic chapters, there's a
lot of
>> you could say geological
>> events,
>> wars, rumors, wars
>> that could be,
>> you know, pretty dramatic for the end of
time. So,
>> in light of all that, what we did is we
said, "Hey, let's invite a geologist on
and talk about that."
>> Yeah. What do they think about geology
and end time prophecy? Let's do it.
>> So, we have with us today Ryan Thompson.
He is a geologist with a master's in
geoscience from Colorado um State
University. And uh he's going to talk to
us today about this whole idea from film
and the Bible and all of this geology.
So, I'm I think this is going to be very
interesting. So, welcome Ryan. It's glad
to have you here.
>> Well, thank you so much Keith, Scotty,
and Denique for having me on today. and
thank you so much for all that you do
and the great content you put out. I'm
really excited to get to talk with you
guys today about science fiction meeting
science reality or potential reality.
So, thank you.
>> Awesome. Have you always done geology
or?
>> Yeah, so I've always loved doing
outdoorsy type things growing up doing
uh nature walks and then uh getting into
the whole creation evolution debate and
realizing the best way to study that was
through through geology. So, I've been
on dinosaur digs and fossil fish hunts
and um then worked in, as you said, in
oil business for like 10 years. And now
I teach though online and I teach math
and science. So, not so much geology.
It's uh more my hobby these days, but
definitely uh studying geology uh from
an end times perspective. And that's
what's very intriguing is most
geologists are are looking in the past
and you're taking that you have a
totally different spin that I've never
heard of and you do a lot of looking in
the future when it comes to geology.
So what is this unique perspective that
you have?
>> Yeah, so it is a bit of a unique
perspective and some people might be
like, oh wait a second, evaluating the
future geologically. But what we have to
remember is that from the creator's
perspective, he's seen it all. Right? He
knows the end from the beginning. So
while most creation scientists take the
present processes on Earth and they look
back at Genesis and a global flood of
Noah's day, which you know, we weren't
there to observe, but we can see present
geological processes and begin to
understand some of what happened during
Noah's day. Okay. My unique perspective
is to do the same thing but as if the
future were also history, right? Because
it is to God the creator. And so we can
take the record which is the Bible's
last book of Revelation and evaluate it
geologically as well. And for me being a
geologist, when I'm reading it, my
neurons are just firing off. I'm going,
"Wow, okay, there's so much uh geologic
stuff in here if we're looking at it
from a literal perspective." And so I
think the reason for that is because
Revelation is really a book about
geology. The second most common word in
Revelation in the Greek is G. Okay? And
that's the root of the word geology or
the study of the earth. So G in Greek,
earth in English, right? The second most
common word in revelation. The first
most is theo or God, right? So,
Revelation is a book primarily about God
and his character, but also about
geology. And the central message of
Revelation, I believe, is right in the
middle of the book in Revelation 14:7,
where it talks about the first angel's
message, right? Fear God and worship him
who made heaven and earth, the sea, and
the springs of water. So, it's a call
back to worship the creator. And so I
believe all the geologic catastrophes
and and things that are described in
Revelation as happening to the earth are
all designed to point us back to the
creator in the same way that the
geological events in Genesis and the
record there points us to the creator.
>> It's like the second book, right? God's
second book is nature.
>> Yeah. There's so many spiritual truths
in the earth that tell us about what's
going on here that God can plop you in
the middle and and I mean that's how he
started it out in a garden, right?
>> Here, tend to this thing. This will
teach you about me. You know,
>> I just I just think it's so fascinating
that, you know, like we just discussed a
little bit about the movies and stuff
like that. I've never looked at the
Bible from a geological perspective
before. I mean, that's just not in my
brain because I don't deal with that
kind of stuff. But but it's true, you
know, as we were talking about um what
is Armageddon, like an ice age, a comet
coming toward the earth or a meteor
that's literally in Daniel, too.
>> Mhm.
>> So, I I'm curious to hear from your
perspective about like, you know, as you
go into this this presentation about the
the Bible and geology, because now that
I'm hearing you talk about this, it
seems like there is this priming in this
other direction away from the Bible. How
likely are these endtime scenarios that
the movies are portraying? You know,
whether it be this, you know, putting
like I'm trying to segregate in my mind
like putting the Bible aside a little
bit, but like from the picture that
people are are having painted for them,
how likely are these end time scenarios
from a geologic perspective?
So from a geologic perspective, I think
actually Hollywood has gotten things
pretty close to the truth and they've
they've used their imagination, which I
think is exactly what we should do when
we're looking at these prophecies is we
shouldn't just, well, this has never
happened before, therefore it will never
happen again. Right? That's that's the
trap that the the antidolivians fell
into at the time of Noah's flood. It's
never rained. It'll never rain. And
then, you know, the floods came and and
so we we do want to use our
imaginations. Uh but I think that
Hollywood takes it a little too far,
right? There's a twist. So, while
they're close to the truth, Hollywood
has uh two goals, right? And one of
those is to instill fear. And this is
exactly opposite what Jesus wants to do,
right? So if you go to Luke 21:26,
it says that men's hearts are failing
them for fear of what is coming towards
the earth.
And so that is what Satan wants. He he
wants us to live in fear of God, right?
Uh not in love and awe of God. And so
when you see Hollywood's propaganda that
they put out, right? It's all about a
fear-based response, right? Suddenly
you're you're looting, rioting and um
going off to to kill people and because
there's nothing left to live for an
asteroid's going to come and doom us
all. So we just revert to our baser
animal instincts. Whereas contrast that
with what Jesus is saying he's saying,
you know, when you see these things
begin to happen, look up, right? So
don't react in fear. Keep looking. Look
beyond the scary that's coming to what's
coming next. Right? because these are
just signs of his second coming. And so
we should be filled with hope that the
King of Kings is coming as a rescue,
right? And so the second thing Hollywood
does is it's propaganda to condition a
certain response, right? And so when we
see these things happening, we react,
you know, humanity reacts in fear and
then Jesus comes back and we're
conditioned by these movies to, you
know, save ourselves, right? Humanism,
like the Tower of Babel all over again
where we need to, you know, attack
whatever is coming down out of the sky
and defeat it, right? We're going to go
and attack the King of Kings, right? But
that's the mentality of these movies,
right? Humanity can save itself. And and
today we're we're trying to do the same
thing, right? We're trying to develop um
commercial space programs now where we
can go and colonize Mars, right? It's
exactly that same tarable mentality of
of saving ourselves so we do not have to
be a part of Messiah's kingdom. But
yeah, that's what I'm looking forward
to. So can you give some examples of
like recent geologic catastrophes that
are you know serving as as warnings? You
know I think this is a big question in
people's mind because
people want to automatically ascribe
something as
um from God know like an act of God an
act of judgment. And I do think God
allows acts of judgment or you know
there's another perspective that says
you know this is all from Satan like you
read in the book of Job and then Satan
causes things to happen on the earth.
What would you use as a modernday or
recent example?
>> Yeah. So this year is the 45th
anniversary of the eruption of Mount St.
Helens. And I think that is a fantastic
example of a catastrophic event that
really struck at the heart of the theory
of evolution because that eruption
actually acted as a catalyst for the
modern creation science movement.
There's always been creation scientists
around who study it from um study, you
know, various aspects of creation from a
a believing faith-based perspective. But
it really took off after that
catastrophic event in Mount St. Helens,
right? Because evolution is based on
again this idea of millions of years of
slow gradual geologic change whereas man
this volcano just erupted in my
backyard. How can I believe that the
theory of evolution is legit? Right? And
so I think we're going to see more and
more of that happen like the the
earthquake in Turkey in February of 2023
in which this massive fracture just
ripped across an olive orchard there.
And I just I have a hard time believing
that if there were any um atheists or
evolutionists standing on either side of
that rift before it opened, I I have a
hard time believing that they would
actually still believe in slow
geological gradual change after that
rift opened. And so then looking at
Revelation, right, and you see these
even more massive, more spectacular
geological catastrophes coming, it's
like, yeah, it's going to be hard for a
lot of people to believe in slow,
gradual change. And thus the theory of
evolution.
>> What What about, for example, like in in
light of Keith's question, the Palisades
fires where all these celebrities were
living, um, tons of Christians came out
and said, "Oh, that's an act of God."
like God is punishing those people,
which I personally feel like makes God
look kind of evil and bad. But, you
know, from your perspective as a
geologist, yeah. Is that perhaps, you
know, an act of God or is that actually
geologically explained? Uh, I mean, even
climate change came up in in that
conversation.
>> Yeah. So, I don't think that the
scriptures are telling us that God is an
evil God and that he's um vengeful and
just wants to punish his creation for
their wickedness. I think what's going
on here is that these these signs and
plagues are just a natural um
consequence of the fact that the earth
is wearing out and
humanity's lived on it for several
thousand years now. It's been violent,
chaotic, and we've done a lot of things
to destroy our planet, and it's just
it's it's finally reacting to that. And
so, these are kind of natural
consequences.
And what's really really awesome is
again not a message of fear but a
message of hope because in each one of
these um plagues that are coming there's
an a matching promise in scriptures
specifically for that plague. Every
single one of the plagues in Revelation
has its own promise of protection. And
so an example of that would be when the
fourth bowl is poured out and um men are
cursing God because of the the excessive
heat from the sun scorching them, right?
And then you go to Psalms 121 5 and 6.
It says uh the Lord is your keeper. The
Lord is your shade at your right hand.
The sun shall not strike you by day.
Right? There's a promise, right? Right?
And so a promise of protection. And so
you have this this this
faith and this assurance that there will
be places and times where those who are
following God and trusting in God will
be preserved from these events that are
going on around them. Because at least
to start these events are not global,
right? You have um warm wood for example
that only impacts a third of the rivers.
That's the um third trumpet. The second
trumpet and I think it's uh only a third
of the trees are burned up. Right? So
they're not global. There is a place of
refuge and there's the promises of
provision and safety. This is very
interesting because, you know, we're
talking about movies and and
future geologic events and yet we see
this in Revelation and we see, you know,
there there's similarities. And
typically when we approach the Bible or
things of the Bible, we take a
historicist perspective, which we've
done many times on this show. It's like
when you're interpreting Bible prophecy,
like most of those things are rooted in
a historical event that has already
happened and there are a few things that
are maybe yet future. So, how does this
type of interpretation work with a
historicist approach? Well, yeah. So,
we're talking about geological events
happening in the future. And I don't
want anyone to think that I'm throwing
the historicist approach to interpreting
prophecy under the bus because I I
really do believe that God has allowed
us to interpret prophecy in many
different ways in order to, you know,
spur uh hope and revival and a return to
him throughout history. And so you have
different ways of interpreting prophecy.
You have the spiritual or symbolic and
you have the literal. Right? So when I'm
looking at geological and events
happening in prophecy, I'm looking at a
very literal understanding of revelation
and that's in no way to throw out the
symbolic or the spiritual because often
those two happen in parallel. And I'll
just give you an example of that. The
crucifixion of our Messiah, right? Where
there was a a great conflict going on
between the adversary and and Jesus. And
that was of course happening in the
spiritual realm. And of course, we know
who's victorious there and who rose
again. Um, but at the same time that
that spiritual conflict was reaching its
pinnacle, the earth also shook and there
was a massive earthquake, right, that
tore the veil in the temple from top to
bottom. And so there you have an example
of the the spiritual and the the literal
physical happening together, right? And
we know prophecy repeats itself. So you
have um the famous prophecy of Jesus
about the destruction of Jerusalem which
occurred in 70 AD, right? He he looks at
those uh beautiful massive stones of the
temple and he's like there's going to
come a time when not one of these stones
is found one on top the other. They're
all going to be thrown down. And that
happened in 70 AD with the destruction
of the temple and they pushed all those
stones off the uh the temple platform.
But the platform itself is still there,
right? In fact, the what's called the
western stone, it's like 250 ton stone
and it's still sitting there in place.
It hasn't been thrown down yet. And so
we go future into prophecy. When the
Messiah returns in Zechariah 14 and his
feet touch the earth for the first time,
the Mount of Olives splits in two. Well,
the Mount of Olives is only like two
less than 2 km away from these massive
stones that make up the Western Wall.
And so imagine an earthquake that's big
enough to split the Mount of Olives is
also finally also going to
completely just demolish any man-made
structures around there as well. So
there's kind of a a man-made fulfillment
of the destruction of the temple in
Jerusalem at 70 AD, but then there's
also a a God event at the end that just
I mean trumps it, right? Ultimate
fulfillment of the prophecy. Revelation
is broken up into many um different you
could say pockets of seven. So for
example, you have like the seven
churches and the seven trumpets and the
seven bowls and the seven seals. These
are all different aspects of
um history you could say and they deal
with uh those different aspects of
history and there's crossover between
the different eras. So, for example, you
have the seven churches, and that would
largely be focusing on events having to
do with the church throughout history.
The seven when you get to things like
the seven trumpets and the seven bulls,
these are going to be more um
judgmentoriented.
It could um it could be talking about
for example how God's
um dealing with the human race
throughout history and as it relates to
judgment. Um so just yeah that's just
kind of a like where this is going. It's
not like there are necessarily seven
bowls that God has that he's like okay
well in here we're going to dump this
out on the earth. It's it's symbolic
language and it's how God is dealing
with humanity in different periods of
history in different ways. It could be
through judgment. It could be through
the church. It could be military. It
could be political. Like they all
represent different aspects. So I think
that's kind of like to show where your
heart is at. You know, it's like if you
think about what happened to Pharaoh,
right? Every single time. How many times
did he actually have to Okay, that was
crazy. This this thing that just
happened. Okay, I'm sorry. you know,
I'll respect God. And it was just like
it kept going deeper and deeper. And I
think that God is proving to the
universe, look, look at there. You can
do all these things that happened to you
and you still don't turn around. So all
these bulls being poured out, you know?
It's like I I think it's like last ditch
effort like guys wake up, you know?
Yeah. So these warning signs are
designed to get people into the place of
safety and refuge, right? So coming down
out of heaven is a new Jerusalem, right?
It's like a spaceship
in which we can be be saved through the
catastrophes that that are coming. And
the the parallel would be the ship the
ark in which um Noah's family was saved
during the flood.
And I'm not the first to kind of draw
the parallel between these two things.
If you go to second Peter and you start
in verse five and six. So Peter starts
his description of the end times with a
reminder of the flood, right? With a
reminder of an actual geological event.
So why should we expect the the final
event to be any different, right? He's
setting the context for us and that's
the flood.
And then in verse seven, he says that
now the ultimate destruction will be
fire. Right? Even the elements are going
to melt with fervent heat. So at some
point these these warnings have
progressed to the point where you know
life on earth is inhospitable right the
the very elements are melting but
there's a place of refuge in the new
Jerusalem
and and outside the new Jerusalem all
the works and as Peter says in second uh
Peter uh 3:10 all the works are burned
up uh all the works in creation. So
those are what God made is completely
burnt. And so there's there's a parallel
in the life of every believer, right?
And that is uh baptism.
And so baptism is just the Greek word
for immersion. We know that the entire
world was immersed at the flood. It was
completely covered by water. And when
Noah and his family got off the earth,
got off the ark, they contributed to an
earth
that was reborn, right? and they
repopulated it.
And so that is what happens when we are
baptized and born again. But then
there's also after that there's the pen
day of Pentecost when the Holy Spirit
comes and fills the new believers. And
so just like that happens in the
believer's life also the earth is
baptized by fire at the end. Okay, this
is what what Peter is driving towards
this this fire that entirely consumes
the earth with the exception of the
what's inside the new Jerusalem, right?
And what happens next is that that now
there can be recreation, right? The
earth itself can be made new after that.
So reborn after the flood, after
baptism, recreated after the spirit
descends, and there's a baptism by fire.
And so all hell is
is what is going on outside of the new
Jerusalem. It has a definitive start. It
has a definitive end. It doesn't last
for very long. And its purpose is just
to consume those who decided that they
would rather not live a life of love and
in harmony with God and their fellow
man. And they choose to be outside of
the city where there's certain
destruction. They have chosen their own
fate. That's all hell is, is a point in
time in which there is a destruction by
fire. Just like the pre flood world and
the inhabitants of it perished, drowned
in the flood. That's entirely 100% hell.
There is no eternally burning fire
because it the world has to be recreated
after that,
>> right?
>> Yeah.
>> The verbiage that the Bible uses the
smoke went up forever and ever. And you
know when you kind of look back at what
happened in Sodom and Gomorrah and the
smoke is ascending forever and ever.
Well, we don't see smoke from uh Sodom
and Gomorrah today. So the idea that
that is a forever thing just doesn't
work.
>> Yeah. You really have to study the when
you study the hell hellfire concept. Um
there's there seems to be seems to be a
contradicting statement because here you
have the words forever and here you have
many many scriptures that say clearly no
there the wicked are burned up. There's
ashes under your feet like you said,
Sodom and Gomorrah. It's burned up. So,
either the Bible contradicts itself or
it doesn't. And it's never has. So, so,
uh, I want to refer our viewers to a
website called helltruth.com where any
of these questions are actually answered
from a biblical point of view. And when
I first studied this, I was amazed. Um,
but that's just a quick quick um, you
know, reference right there.
>> If you want a more cinematic movie style
uh, story, Helen Mr. Fudge also is
something that dealt with that topic. So
>> yeah, we got a video on our on our
channel as well with Mikey who used to
be here. He did it in uh he discussed
hell in the format of uh hot ones. So
that's another option. But but Ryan,
what what what else uh do you have on
this? You had another thought.
>> Yeah. So thinking about our theme for
today and Hollywood and how it imagines
hell, right?
And I I I think I picture Gollum right
from Lord of the Rings and he's going
down into the fires of of Mount Doom.
He's he's going into a lake of fire
inside a volcano clinging to his
precious, right? His his sins as it
were. Then you've got the Terminator,
right? He's choosing to go into a vat of
molten metal, right? No one's putting
him in there. He's going down with his
thumbs up. You know, I'll do it my way,
right?
And um so that's kind of the the end of
the story, right? But now getting back
to the beginning, how do we get there?
And so I want to start where Hollywood
often starts with asteroids. And that's
a little bit out of my domain, right?
Because we're talking about astrophysics
now and not geology. But the thing with
um asteroids is is they're mentioned in
prophecy
kind of towards the beginning, right?
You have the second trumpet where a
asteroid hits the sea. The third where
it hits the rivers. That's the one
that's called Wormwood. And then you've
got the fifth trumpet where a celestial
object impacts the earth and unlocks the
bottomless pit and smoke arises. Right?
And so I think the reason why Hollywood
is so obsessed with it is I think the
Bible is also obsessed with it. And
so Luke especially actually if you go to
you know three of the gospels record
Jesus final prophetic discourse and Luke
really focuses on the celestial events
more than the others. And so in Luke 21
26, he's talking about men's heart
failing for fear because of things.
There awaiting things arriving to earth,
right? Something's coming from space
towards the earth. And
so these things will have a geologic
um impact. There will be geological
events associated with not just an
impact on the earth, but even a near
miss. So if the asteroid just went
flying pi by, it still could have
consequences, geological consequences on
Earth. So how does that work? Right? So
if you have a a large geologster,
it can actually pull the Earth a little
bit closer to it. Right? So gravity
works um both ways, right? So when you
dive off a diving board into water,
you're moving towards the center of the
Earth. But the Earth also very slightly
moved towards you and it does it
proportionally right to its mass and
your mass. Okay, talking about a large
asteroid mass, it'll have a little bit
more of an impact on the Earth. And the
idea that there could be a orbital shift
isn't necessarily without historical
precedent. So Joshua, right, he commands
the the sun and the moon to stand still.
Hezekiah
sees a sund dial move backwards 15°.
And we know that at the time of the
flood, it's recorded in in Genesis for
us that the rains fell for 150 days. But
it's also told us that that period was
also 5 months. And so we know that at
one point in the past, the Earth's orbit
was closer to the sun and we were on a
360 dayear calendar, not 3605 like it is
today.
And so an orbital slip I think has
occurred in the past and it's I think
possible that it could in the future.
Now this is this is a hypothesis. It's
kind of wild speculation. Um but that's
what prophetic interpretation is, right?
We need to be careful not to hold our
prophetic interpretations too closely
because at the end of the day,
interpretation is just a nice word for
speculation and hypothesis is just a
nice word for speculation.
And so we can come up with these
different ideas and and test them and
see which one fits the best. Um, but we
got to live it. We got to wait to see it
happen, right? To really know for sure.
Um, so the idea I'm going to throw out
there is that asteroids can cause the
Earth's orbit to slip and that when they
do so, it causes geological events to
occur on Earth. Okay? And I'm going to
go so far as to say that I think the
Bible is actually point blank telling us
that this is what happens.
>> Do you remember that earthquake that
happened in Indonesia or it hit
Indonesia? I guess the tsunami hit
Indonesia. The earthquake hit the whole
earth. It was like a 9.2 magnitude or
something. Was it around 200
five six? I don't 2004.
>> Yeah. I thought I remembered reading
that that had shifted the earth somehow
as well.
>> Yeah. So that was actually 2004 when
that um tsunami hit and it was caused by
an earthquake on a on a convergent plate
tectonic boundary. And when you move
masses around, right, if you say you
have a top a spinning top and you you
know move the mass around, it's going to
change how that top spins.
And that's exactly what happens with the
Earth. So, it's entirely possible.
>> How in the world, no pun intended, would
you measure that?
>> Good question for him.
>> I mean, that's like that's like that's
like such a crazy thing. Like, you know,
like this massive ball, how would you
even know if it went like a degree, you
know what I mean? Or like
>> Yeah.
>> off course. Yeah. Yeah. That's that's a
that's an interesting thought, though.
Yeah.
>> How you would how you would see it is
you would just observe a change in the
length of days in a year or days in a
month, right? So I think it's possible
that God could put us back on that
calendar where it's 360 days per year
and that obviously we would notice.
>> Yeah. Summer winter's happening at a
different kind of space than it used to
or something, you know. Interesting.
>> Yeah. So Isaiah 13:13 then says,
"Therefore, I will shake the heavens and
the earth will move out of her place."
And the there's a couple interesting
Hebrew words in there that just like
really pop to me as a geologist. And the
first one is um I'm going to probably
pronounce it horribly, mimic. Uh it's
one Hebrew word but from it we get the
idea that the earth is being moved out
of its usual place. Okay. And then it
says that the heavens are shaken and
there the Hebrew word is ragaz. Um so
okay clearly not an earthquake right
because the heavens are what is shaken.
So what what is this right? The heavens
are shaken and the earth is no longer in
the same place. Uh that's uh a little
odd to contemplate. Um
so the the Hebrew language is really
really rich when it comes to words that
have to do with shaking. Unfortunately
in the English they're all translated as
shaking. Um but you got to remember that
the Holy Land sits on a um a plate
boundary between the Arabian plate and
the African plate. And those are moving
apart, which is why the Dead Sea is so
deep and dropping down where it is. It's
on those it's dropping down along these
faults as these two plates move apart.
And um so they've got lots of words to
describe shaking in all its different
ways that the earth moves and shakes. So
let's go to Isaiah 24 for another couple
Hebrew words about shaking. And it says
there that the foundations of the earth
shake. Okay. The earth is violently
broken and the earth is split open. The
earth slips completely. And I've put in
my own translation there. Um it most of
the translations this is Isaiah 24:18
say the earth is utterly shaken. Okay.
But I say the earth slips completely
because in Hebrew it's it's mo. All
right. And when we find a Hebrew word
repeated more than once, it means it's
doing it to completion or doing it
perfectly. Right? So shalom, shalom is
peace. Peace or perfect peace. Um, and
why do I say slip? I say slip because if
you go to Psalm 17:E5,
the psalmist is saying, you know, uphold
me, oh God, and preserve me that my foot
doesn't slip. Okay. So there it's
actually translated as slip. Here it's
translated as shaking. Uh because how
does the earth slip, right? No one can
conceive of that. Well, I can't. I'm a
geologist, right? And so the earth if it
were slip, I mean slipping is a great
descriptor of what happens between
faults, right? you have a plate boundary
or even like the San Andreas fault and
it's one block of rock is moving or
sliding or slipping past the other one,
right? But here it says the entire earth
is doing that. And then if you say where
it says the foundations of the earth are
shaken, a better word for that is
probably leap. Okay, that's the Hebrew
word raash. And it's used in Job 39:20
where it says a locust
raash from one place to another. Right?
So the locust will leap from one place
to another
and um
it's it's s it's in one place and then
suddenly it's in another place. Okay?
And it slips between the two places.
That's what it's telling us. So how does
the foundations of the earth do that?
Obviously in Job it also tells us that
the the earth is hung on nothing. It's
we're not talking about literal
foundations here. Um but what could it
slip on? And the answer is well it could
be slipping on the fabric of spacetime
on the fabric of gravity right the orbit
of the earth is shifting once again and
potentially shifting closer to the sun
right um
and why I say closer to the sun is
because of how that would impact then
certain geological things happening on
earth that are described in revelation.
I think I think I'm I think I'm going on
too much and um so just let me know if I
need any questions.
>> No, no, no. I'm tracking with you. It's
fascinating. You're you're you're you're
going in teacher mode and we're just
like soaking it up.
>> Yeah.
>> So, what happens when
you have a crust that is warming up?
What happens to things as they get
>> hotter? Expand. They get Yeah, they
expand,
>> right? They expand. Things expand when
they get warmer. So how does that drive
an increase in earthquakes? And the
answer to that is so today right the
earth's crust is colder and the fault
planes are being squeezed together. The
earth is in compression not expansion
right not extension. And so as these
faults are being pushed together it's
actually acting as a a dampening effect
on the number of earthquakes. And we
still have major catastrophic
earthquakes,
but nothing compared to what would
happen if the earth were just a little
bit closer to the sun. We would have an
exponential rise in the number of
earthquakes, the severity of
earthquakes, and they would be happening
in diverse places where they haven't
happened before. As as those fault
planes are the the stresses on those
fault loosen, right? as expand as the
crust expands it loosens those faults
and then they can just start slipping
easily all over the place
and so that is how a slight adjustment
very slight adjustment to earth's orbit
could end up kickstarting
the geological changes that go on and
are described in the book of revelation
right the increase in earthquakes and so
along with then the earthquakes starting
to slip more. Right? When you have the
expansion, you're also going to open up
fractures in the earth. And those
fractures are conduits for the magma
under the crust of the earth to come up
through the crust and erupt out as
volcanoes. Right? So, not only do you
have earthquakes, but you also have a
tremendous increase in volcanic activity
and volcanic material being ejected into
the atmosphere, as well as lava flowing
out over the surface of the Earth.
>> And if you have a lot of volcanic
activity, then you're going to create a
lot of ash and soot and things like
that. So, it would have a lot of these
things that, you know, people have
talked about from an evolutionary
perspective. you know, this asteroid hit
the Earth and these volcanoes went off
and it created this cloud of darkness.
So, things like that.
>> Keith, yes, I'm glad you pointed that
out because that's exactly what is
described then. Right in the some of the
later
BS and trumpets after the initial
asteroid impacts, you have darkness. And
the darkness is described as painful
darkness, right? This isn't just
darkness caused by an eclipse. There's
something in that darkness. And I think
that something is the the glass from a
volcanic eruption, right? The little
shards of particles in the volcanic ash.
And this is paralleled right back to um
the plagues of Exodus again where the
darkness was thick and gloomy and the
Egyptians actually had to feel through
it, right? Um,
well, why do you have to feel through
darkness? Because there's stuff in the
darkness, right? Ash in the darkness.
Very much, very much like what was
experienced after Mount St. Helens again
erupted and just blanketed the Pacific
Northwest with a layer of ash and gloomy
darkness that lasted for days, just as
what's talked about in these these
plague events. So, so I'm just curious
like
we see all of these catastrophes in
movies. We see like the floods, like the
meteors like you guys are talking about.
How likely is it
for humans to be able to ward this off?
Because like we've talked in the
beginning, it seems like we're kind of
being uh what do you call it? Like
taught, so to speak, that this is
coming, but you it's inevitable.
>> Yeah. It's it's inevitable, but you can
fight this back. So, I'll give you an
example. Ice Age, for example, I I keep
bringing up this one because it's the
most vivid in my mind that there's this
meteor meteor that came, but they
basically go into a volcano like you
just mentioned. They take these crystals
from this volcanic geyser and um they
work together to hurl a giant crystal
into the volcano, triggering an
eruption. And then an eruption sends the
magnetic crystal shards into the sky
creating a magnetic force field that
deflects the asteroid sending it back
into space from Earth. Um, and then you
have this other one we talked about
Armageddon. I remember seeing this as a
kid where they drill a nuclear weapon
into the core of the it detonated and so
it splits into into two and basically
diverts uh from Earth's trajectory. So
>> that that sounded a lot more plausible
than the ice age.
>> Yes. But but you know like just to bring
this up like is it even humanly possible
as it's portrayed in the movies to to
divert an asteroid to stop a flood?
Because when I look at for example the
Palisades fires I'm like that thing just
took all the houses out including of all
of these famous people celebrities movie
stars they couldn't do a thing about it.
They were trying and they just couldn't
stop it.
>> Yeah. You know, Hollywood, I think, is
again trying to condition us for a
specific response. And so, we see an
asteroid coming towards Earth. And we're
not sure if it's going to hit Earth.
It's, you know, we think it will based
on, you know, our calculations. And so,
what do we do? Like you said, we send a
nuke up or
we blow it up and we could be creating
our own problems, right? When suddenly
now instead of one asteroid that God
knew was going to miss, now suddenly
we've got three. the second trumpet, the
third trumpet, the fifth trumpet, right?
We've got all these fragments that are
definitely going to hit Earth now,
right? Um we just humans cannot control
the power of nature. I think that's
that's um very clear and and what's
what's really awesome is that our God,
the creator can, right? Uh thinking
about Sinai
and the fact that you have this amazing
geological event going on at Sinai,
right? the thunder, the mountain
melting, and and and yet God's voice is
heard above that, right? Our creator has
power over his creation. We definitely
don't.
>> You know, you're you're bringing up an
interesting point that I've actually
never thought of cuz I've always watched
those movies way back when, too. Stopped
watching movies years ago, but um um I
always thought that that's ridiculous. I
know that's not how the world is going
to end.
>> Yeah. But how many times does Satan come
at us with a full absolute lie that has
nothing to do with with with the truth,
right? If it's close to the truth.
>> Yes.
>> You see how much more effective that is.
So that's kind of an interesting concept
that you're bringing up that that there
might be some elements that could easily
play into this. Not that it's just like,
oh, absolutely nothing could even come
close.
>> But then we have do have the concept in
the movies as well of this.
>> Stop it. Well, I was going to say this
absolute chaos and fear.
>> So, we are being primed to be fearful of
this thing that's coming
>> and therefore fight it.
>> But the Bible explains,
Ryan, that that we actually there's a
hope and that we can be um seek comfort
and see this as a signs of the times
that our savior is coming to save us
from this earth. So, what are your
thoughts on that, Ryan? You're
absolutely right, Denique. And there is
hope. And that hope is the fact that the
uh second coming of Jesus is a rescue
mission. And it's a rescue mission
because Earth is going to get to the
point where life on this planet actually
becomes unsustainable.
And so,
you know,
winding up to this grand culmination,
this grand crescendo of the final lake
of fire, right? All these geological
events actually they reverse every
single day of creation in its entirety,
right? And
so in Jeremiah 4:25,
it there it uses the same Hebrew word
thou as we find in Genesis to describe
the earth in its precreated state. Only
Jeremiah is talking about it in the
future, right? As and it's the abyss.
It's translated that same Hebrew word in
the Greek is abyss. And that's what we
see in Revelation, right? And in
Jeremiah 4:25 says there's no man. So we
see an undoing of day six of creation
and the creation of man. Um and then as
far as day five right in Jeremiah it
talks about all the birds having fled.
Um we know that all the sea creatures
die in Revelation 16:3.
And um so day five is fully reversed.
The sun, moon, and stars are darkened
over and over again in prophecy. That's
the reversal of day four where those
heavenly luminaries were unveiled. Um
the grass is burned up in Revelation
18:7. Uh sorry, not 188:7.
And the grass being burned up, right?
That's a reversal of day three. But it's
more than that, right? Because you have
the mountains and islands collapsing
into the sea.
And so
that, you know, remember how God on the
third day of creation gathered the land
together
and separated it from the waters. So
that was a tectonic process there and
powered by the creator's voice, right?
And so you see a reversal of that. So
all these earthquakes that we're talking
about that are kind of kickstarted by
this orbital shift uh they they they
increase in intensity to the point where
mountains and islands are collapsing and
they continue right the volcanism
continues all the way up to the final
lake of fire.
So okay that's day three and then um 2
Peter 3:10 we've already talked about
that right where the elements are
melting with fervent heat. Obviously,
the atmosphere that was created on day
two entirely burned up. Isaiah 34 says
uh verse 4 that the sky is rolled up
like a scroll. Okay, it's it's gone. And
at that very moment when we can't even
breathe anymore. That's when Jesus
returns to rescue us, right? Ultimately,
even day one is reversed. Jeremiah 4:23
says that there is no light anymore.
Okay? And um so what's going on here?
Right, we have this massive earthquake
that's talked about in the sixth seal,
the seventh trumpet, and the seventh
bowl. And um Ezekiel 34:12 says that the
sheep are rescued on a cloudy and dark
day. U which is exactly that thick
clouds and dark glooiness that we're
talking about and that volcanic ash,
right? And Jesus is coming back. John 12
uh 12:47,
not to judge the world, but to save or
rescue the world. Right. That was his
mission the first time. That's his
mission coming again.
>> Ryan,
>> you're blowing my mind.
>> That is a kayastic structure if I've
ever seen one.
>> Yeah,
>> that's amazing.
>> Almost like the entire world is
mimicking the structure that God had.
Like, wow, I've never thought of that
before. That's amazing.
>> But you know what's what's even more
fascinating when you think about that?
What are the implications of that? If
the earth is brought to a place where
even people now believe that the earth
is going to be unsustainable, they just
see it as like in the future like way on
out like eventually it's going to happen
because of global warming and all these
other things. But if you bring the earth
to a place where it's unsustainable and
you're on the earth, you should realize
you got two options. You can keep
fighting against it or you can recognize
Jesus as your Lord and Savior and as
your only source of hope
>> to get out of that mess.
>> How galvanized would you have to be?
>> I think God is very merciful and I think
like I like the fact that you brought up
Noah.
Those people were making fun of Noah all
the way up to the second they started
seeing the raindrops. Then it was like
trying to fasten themselves to the sides
and you know all sorts of stuff, right?
I think that God, what happens when he
often um passes these judgments, it's
like it's like a getting punished as a
child, right? That should correct what
you're doing. But if you are defiant,
defiant, defiant, defiant, defiant, then
that pretty much shows the universe
you're you're not going to turn around.
>> And in and in the plagues, when you look
at those, it's easy to look at them, you
know, as pretty harsh,
>> but every step of the way, there's mercy
>> that God is offering to people. And
>> so it's like, okay, now I just destroyed
this thing and it's going to make it
hard, but there's this crop over here
that's still preserved that, you know,
is in the process of springing up and
you'll have food. You know, the call is
to turn to me now. And they harden their
hearts and, you know, a Pharaoh does. He
turns away from that and then the next
thing is destroyed. And it's like, well,
I still have a plan. I can still help
you. I can still save you, but you need
to turn to me. And I see that what he's
describing is the same thing is
happening.
>> Yeah. And if you're seeing those people
that are truly on God's side protected,
>> that's another act of mercy for you to
look. Why are you not experiencing this
what I'm experiencing? Why is this thing
skipping over you? Which should
ultimately make you go, uh, what what's
going on here? Like, let's talk about
this.
>> Yes.
>> And that's God's mercy.
>> And this is why it's so important that
we're in the Bible and not into pop
culture. Ironically, you're wearing real
eyes. Real eyes. Real eyes. I'm wearing,
let me show you.
>> What would Jesus watch? And then Keith
is also wear wearing uh one of the
prophecy shirts. Yes. But uh you know,
we got plenty of t-shirts like like that
on lightwware.shop. So if you want to
spread the message, get in the word, not
in the media.
>> These are conversation starters. I mean,
I was I was walking through the airport
and and I walked right by one of those
kind of like bars that are out there.
Dude, the bartender goes, "Nice shirt."
And so I walk over and I have this whole
conversation from him and it's like,
"Yeah, that's a good good reason to wear
the wear the truth right on your chest."
>> Share the message. Get in the word, not
in the what? We've got one that says uh
the Facebook logo and it's like get your
face in the lamb's
book.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> So
obviously depending on your perspective,
this looks pretty grim, but we see a lot
of hope. And I see like it makes it more
real in my mind that if all these things
are being, you know, creation in reverse
and God's people obviously needing to be
protected when God says your bread and
water will be sure, that has to be a
supernatural event because you can't
provide for yourself anymore. There's no
way to do that.
>> There's no crops. The crops are gone.
>> Yeah. Completely dependent upon God. So
there's no nothing that you're doing
essentially to provide for your
salvation. and you're just cooperating
with God's plan and saying, "Okay, Lord,
I'm here."
>> Even more miraculous when all those
resources are taken away and God's
people are still fed that another reason
to be on the right side.
>> Debt fish, debt birds, and dead grass.
Where are you going to get it from?
Well, God provides.
>> Yeah. What are what are I mean, thinking
about this, God's God's purpose is to to
save the world, not to judge the world.
You know, the Bible even says in John
3:16, "I did not come well, it's not
3:16, but 3:17, I did not come to
condemn the world." Right? That's not
that's not the purpose of his coming.
Um, and then we're going to be
eventually
removed, you know, just like he talked
about in the beginning, that
recolonization,
only it's God's colonization pro program
where we go to the new new Jerusalem,
not Mars. And then we're back to where
we started, right, Ryan?
>> Right. Except for the sin problem.
>> Yeah. Without the sin part.
>> That's true.
>> But but that Yeah, that's even that's
even more amazing that See, there's a
chastic right there. You get into the
sin in the end. The world is reversed,
destroyed, and you have the sin problem
solved.
>> And then what happens? Because it's not
completely done after that. I mean
there's that we go to the new Jerusalem,
but there's more there's one more
geological event you might say that's
happening. Walk us through that.
>> Yeah. One last geological event where
you know Revelation 21
now there's a new heavens and a new
earth, right? We get to see recreation,
right? we get to see that um hellscape
uh converted back into paradise.
>> Be awesome.
>> So, right.
>> So, I have a cool rock question for you.
Were you a little kid that like just put
rocks in your pockets and your parents
would do the washing machine and it'd be
like just rocks roaming around in there?
>> I definitely was the kid that started
collecting rocks and I would line them
up next to my baseboard. Don't know that
they ever really made it into my pockets
though. Wanted to see them.
>> Um, why is gold transparent? How is that
even possible?
>> Well, if you get it thin enough, then it
would be
>> Yeah, you get it thin enough.
>> Well, then if it's thin enough to see
through, isn't it? It's not really
there.
>> It's pretty thin. No, it's just super
thin. So, gold from a chemistry
perspective, I remember it's the most
malleable. So you can take an ounce of
gold and hammer it out to the size of a
tennis court.
>> Wow.
>> So
>> yeah, it's got it's got some crazy
properties as an element.
>> That's crazy.
>> Yeah, man. I'm looking forward to it. A
city with 12 foundations of different
cool stones, you know? It's like
heaven's going to be this just like
absolutely and and I like how the Bible
describes that, too. City Jerusalem with
the gates and the pearls and I mean
there's just like
>> it's going to be awesome.
>> Be awesome. Don't miss out. Noah made
his ark out of wood and God is making
his place of refuge out of gold and
jewels. It's going to be awesome.
>> So that's that's a that's a pretty
interesting picture and definitely
different than one that Hollywood has
painted for us. Certainly the one that
we have has a lot more hope than what
Hollywood is giving. So thank you for
sharing that. It's been very uh
educational to say the least and I think
just reinforces how much hope that the
Bible's actually offering. And so if you
as a viewer want to know more about
these things, Ryan has actually written
a book and um you can get that on
Amazon. You can leave a review there. So
we'll put a link in the description
below so that you can pick that up and
support his work and also learn more
about this perspective. Any closing
thoughts from anybody?
>> Yeah. Uh thank you so much Keith and
Scotty and Denique for such a wonderful
uh time today. It just got me all fired
up all over again. Thank you.
>> No, that was really fascinating. I love
it. Um just the the study of of nature
and then the conjunction with the Bible,
it I just I just think the the word is
such an amazing book. I mean, there's
just so rich and deep and and you know,
there's a reason why God just says, "Dig
dig deep into this thing because you
will you will understand and we'll
forever study that thing." I mean, that
that to me is amazing.
>> I mean, what what are you going to do a
billion years down the road?
>> Yeah.
>> And you're still going to be like mind
blown like, "No way. That was amazing."
>> Yeah. I I was Scotty, get your get your
head in in the lamb's book, God's word.
Um, and I think we all have gained a
different perspective now of of the
Bible from a geological point of view.
And uh, yeah, let's spend time in God's
word and away from this media that
really deceives us and turns us away
from Jesus. Let's turn toward Jesus.